name a film i could tell you one thing
we could change about for drive very
easy for drive i think the number one
thing i would change with that film
what's the most you've rewatched a film
in the theater same film
god do i want to answer this
it's probably a tie is it paddington
oh god paddington too oh
yeah plea that unbelievable no i did not
say that multipliers i i think the the
film i've seen the most in theaters was
lost boys
because of that initial experience as
this 80s kid going in and getting blown
away by oh talk about one of the best
soundtracks of all time i mean lost boys
that i had the cd for not the cassette i
had the cd for lost boys and between
listening to that cd back forth back
forth and then going to see the film so
many times that summer right uh and the
other one would be cocktail
same time period i was a kid we were
bored you know it's summertime you're
like let's go to the movies and let's go
see something and let's go see cocktail
again i took multiple dates to see
cocktail it was the ultimate date film
sure and this was in columbus ohio okay
columbus ohio uh those are probably the
two and they each won probably six times
um even though i don't like to admit i
have seen fire starter now five times
the most recent one because it's 90
minutes long and there was nothing else
to see and i was bored and i'm five
minutes from this from the theater
that's why i went to see it five times
but i think you know what really the the
brevity of a film
adds to its rewatch ability
because if if you're talking about a
three-hour film
then you're you have to commit three
hours to that right that's a that's a
major time commitment conversely if a
movie's 85 90 95 minutes
it's day you can watch it twice in the
time it takes to watch the other movie
once and you know one of my again a film
that oh i absolutely adore and from a
filmmaker that i think is going to
really bring stuff that we is going to
be one of our major major filmmakers in
years to come is uh is rose glass
i mean you you you look at
saint maude saint maude is
talk about a film you get blown away by
the direction and the choices and the
talent behind the the screen
uh
that that is that is a film that uh is
is again rewatchable for that length as
well it's an 85 90 minute movie i think
that more filmmakers need to remember
that less is more less is more such an
important thing
if you can say something tighter do it
if you can make a movie tighter
almost all the time do it look at the
irishman three and a half hours right
and now netflix's has this whole thing
about you know it was a vanity project i
think someone actually added that quote
to what netflix said but but when you
watch
irishmen or you watch a lot of things
that come out of netflix you are looking
at a film that doesn't have the studio
constraints that are needed put upon it
and when i say that you go back to the
80s 90s
2000s studios had more control over
their films they said this is the studio
head would say hey listen your film is
going to come in at
140 you're going to come in at 90. 150
max now we're bleeding into 220 230 245
and unless it's necessary vital to your
film less is more
almost always
so many films that i see you say man
there's a better version here if you
would have taken things out not added
you had the opportunity to make this
really well certainly a better film and
you left more in this to
lessen its overall quality and i think
that that gets back to the director
you have to have somebody who you trust
to watch your projects and say listen
i like what i see but
i think you need to do this this and
this and i think there's not enough of
that in hollywood and i know some
creatives will think oh man that is
sacrilegious what you're saying but
if it makes your project better then
you should be listening to those people
who hopefully have a very good track
record it's saying this is what i think
will do we can do to improve your film
okay so taking the less is more analogy
let's look at the social network and
let's look at the dialogue
so
the dialogue was just right you think
sorkin screenplay is again
social network is there's it's a
flawless film it's uh which is
those don't come along often okay i
don't care what film even parasite i've
got which i of recent films which i
think is again a masterpiece i think
there's a there's a couple things that i
would change drive is a film that i oh
god i love drive uh i've seen dr i
probably have seen drive 40 times that's
a film that
uh really it speaks to me as a la person
for sure 40. oh yeah oh yeah i've
watched that i just watched in a loop
it's a background it's one of those
films you put on the background right
and you just have and it just makes you
feel even though drive trust me
depressing film but the feels the score
martinez's score and drive is just
something i can listen to it's on my
it's on my ipod on my on my phone i
listen to that thing all the time um it
just takes me to a space that is that
film and i'll never forget that's
another cinematic first that i'll never
forget the first watching of drive and a
press screen and i'm oh my god this is
reffin wow uh and again it speaks to
love of los angeles and i think he nails
it the feels of that film um but but
when you look at at these at social
network and you're talking about a film
that that uh again is perfect i think
this from the screenplay to the uh
against score screenplay direction uh
acting every single element of that film
is perfect so there's not one thing i
would change about a film that's i name
a film i can tell you one thing we could
change about for drive very easy for
drive i think the number one thing i
would change with that film is in the
elevator head stomping scene where he is
he's in there with uh gosling's in there
with mulligan they're in the elevator
you got the bad guy there and he's gonna
do something
terrible to him he starts stomping the
guy's head in and and we get it he's
absolutely obliterating this guy as he's
down on the ground and you don't see it
right you don't see it so refin at the
very end the last shot boom you actually
see his foot go through the heads right
like smashing a pumpkin
i think if you do not show that and you
leave it up here right
it's stronger so restraint
is
often stronger than showing it look at
jaws go back to jaws right we didn't see
it was all in your head if the terror is
in your head if the horror is there then
it's stronger than actually seeing it
i'm not saying that's universally true
but i think in cases like drive and the
elevator scene no question that if
refund would have held off on that
instead pulled back and had left it up
here it's a better film so these are
little things but they matter i mean
ultimately i would love to be like a
test screener of one show me your movie
and trust me i'd have no problem doing
this
raffin would be here and i'd say listen
man film is
you gotta be it's just such a film but
but you the the elevator scene we gotta
get rid of it we gotta get rid of the
head stomping and and
that's what we need we need more of
somebody who has
the ability to judge and probably okay
listen someone could say i'm wrong about
that that's fine but i think after
watching enough films and really
getting dialing in the skill of
evaluation of a film you become
very aware of what works and what
doesn't work and i think that is a very
important skill to have on a studio
level because therefore you could go in
and say for any film and say
i i
i know what i'm saying here i i think we
can make this film better by doing this
this and this and i think we need more
of that
beyond great direction what makes a film
amazing um i think
putting you in a world
creating a world that you escape into
that you are fully immersed in that is
um
it's an experience that again takes you
out of your every day and puts you only
into this it could be anything it could
be modern day it could be past could be
sci-fi it could be horror it doesn't
matter what the genre is you're creating
this full
fully alive world that these characters
live in and if you're able to do that i
think that creating that setting
that that is
so it's crucial to a film it sounds
obvious right but not every film is able
to do that but the best films are the
ones that literally place you
in that location with those characters
and that is again
essential i mean it is absolutely one of
the key things that is needed to be done
by any director filmmaker is to make you
be part of that world and it sounds easy
but it's not and not every film is able
to do that
so with blade runner 82
that world was was just like something
fully realized right
yeah and again think of the time right
so you go back and that's uh
10 20 40 years now is that right uh
40 years ago ish uh you're talking about
uh you know ahead of its time so many
ways
but the production design on that film
um just the sets that were created i
think it's very important to have as
much
real
actual
tangible things in your film versus
everything being cgi right we get
blinded by cgi films these days just so
much of it like doctor strange two
multiverse of madness but you're looking
at a film that has so much cgi from that
opening scene it's just like i am
watching characters in front of a green
screen you literally can see the green
screen in your head you just like
they're in front of a green screen i
think there's so much power in actually
putting those characters in an
environment a true real environment and
that's one of the reasons dune succeeds
so well because the production design of
that film is authentically it's real it
is tangible it is not cgi they're cgi in
the film we know that but
more often than not practical sets are
where these actors are existing and
that is part of the world building
that's part of the production design of
any film i mean one of the best films i
saw from last year nightmare alley
nightmare alley del toro's nightmare
alley is
such an underrated film and one of the
reasons is that production design you
know creating not just the carnival
world but also the noir world of new
york in the 30s
or chicago wherever the city was um you
know creating that world the world
building is just is everything to a film
and it's it's skill again that not every
filmmaker has so i think that's if you
ask me direction very clearly but it all
still comes back to direction doesn't it
i mean when you talk about world
building it's the director's job to
build the world so that's why i say that
the director's everything i mean sure
yeah that script's important
but but the director's
skill and his artistic vision is by far
to me the number one skill that you need
to have as a filmmaker